all right hi everyone we are talking
about hierarchical entities
i've forgotten if we live streamed the
previous iteration of this
um
but uh
uh if we
didn't um
well let's see this is about
what are these creatures
wait a minute an entity
okay
has a subtype
that is a species
subtype that is a bird i see winged
entity all right so we have
some kind of partial ordering here we
think
is it a partial ordering or is it
something more complicated
yes a partial order or a lattice
okay
okay
you know one day we should have some
functions that are specifically about
partial orders and post sets and so on
because they just seem to come up all
over the place
um
maybe
logic package
ah
oh gosh is that i don't even know the
um
i guess that's another place they show
up okay all right so now what will guide
me through what we're talking about here
yes so the first diagram above is just
to illustrate the idea of a concrete
type and then specializations thereof
and going up more abstract types now
and um
below
we see a prototype
of
our built-in entities in with the
example of species
this is how the next species really will
be
built on so that's not
it's
that's practical
for instance animals have a body
temperature but other species don't
right
okay
so this is a notion
of progressive specialization
and this is our kind of model of the
world
that things have sub
you know their sub specialization
and that's probably a reasonable model
i mean at this level that's probably
that's probably the next step up
from the notion of entities that we have
right now entities with individual types
this is the subtype type thing
okay
okay so what do we have to figure out
here
oops
so so we can see if if we focus on a
particular animal then
only part of that hierarchy applies
yeah in this case a human
and
humans have a body temperature
and and the new thing is that now you're
mixing types that appear in the entity
first argument and in the entity
property first argument now that is a
new proposed feature
right that if it's a sub entity a
subtype
then it can appear in that way
clearly if i have an entity
well it could be the case that if i have
an entity an animal entity here
now if i say
in this if i say entity animal
homo sapiens will that still work
currently not and
that's not a good thing
the idea is that we should have a unique
identifier if you refer to the same
thing
[Music]
no that's not going to work i mean
i don't understand that
why why wouldn't you be able to use
a subtype
if this thing because we know this thing
is a member of that sub sub sub subtype
down here right
yes
so we could but what would we gain by
doing that well that you don't have to
remember how to get up to the super type
because what level of super type do you
go to
i mean we could go to the super super
type of just thing
how do we know we're not doing that
and remember we've agreed that
the
naming here
does not have to be unique
across
beyond our
current level of types
that is there's nothing that says that a
you know gold as a color and gold as an
element have to have distinct string
names
they're distinguished by the fact that
they're in different levels of entity
do you get what i'm saying
no different level different punches
different branches yes they're they're
they're different branches
and at what level in that tree are
things disambiguated
right there's there's a different level
of types
that define a scoping of names
than down at the level of animals and so
on in other words if you have an animal
and a fungus
can they have the same string name
yes or no
i would say no i would also say no
because so tell me at what level
tell me at what level you have
you have the name disambiguation
right you're going to have a level
which is basically our current types
at which there is name disambiguation
and the lower levels
well by by implication there's also name
disambiguation but at higher levels
there isn't name disambiguation
so look looking at
tony's top chart
one candidate would be
the most abstract concrete type so that
the name no
obviously obviously obviously
yeah obviously yeah
so this is the
that's right that's the
but those are the things that we have
currently given type names to so we're
tagging
types of types so to speak
and that is a scoping type
so to speak we can call it you know
something like a scoping type
and
but though i really think it should be
the case i mean the canonical form of
entity animal coma homo sapiens could be
the scoping type
do you see what i'm saying but this is i
think what tony was advertising already
last time that this would be the
canonical version the question very last
time and it was are there non-canonical
versions
okay so the question is if you say
entity animal homo sapiens does it stay
like that or does it evaluate to
taxonomic species
is that correct that's the question
that's that's the version of it yeah
well actually
we should distinguish
entities by representing things should
never evaluate but we could have a
canonicalization
okay whatever i'm not so sure about that
but let's
let's assume okay so then you can say
entity animal homo sapiens and the
system has got to know
that you go to the super type
if you want to disambiguate that you
have to go to the super type
now if i say entity property
i'm sorry if i say entity animal
ragweed which is a plant
that will somehow fail is that correct
or what should that do
some unknown entity
okay that would say unknown entity as a
plant as an animal so to speak even
though it's not unknown as a taxonomic
species
so even though it's scoping type even
though it has a correct enclosing
scoping type it does not have a correct
plot proximal type so to speak
am i making sense yeah
okay so here
then
we can
say
i see so we're looking at entity classes
and we're saying that any
i'm confused by this
normally entity class us
when i say entity class members of the
united nations or something how do i
write that
um control equal
okay but okay
i think that's the difference between
the named entity classes and
implicit entity clauses okay
uh
is that an oh for god's freaking sake is
this still broken
can somebody please report that again
is anybody here who can do that or am i
doing that myself thank you
and you can note this as well because
that's just wrong
okay so there
wait a minute how do i how do i get this
thing entity list
no i don't want energy so i want to see
what this is so ctrl shift a input from
[Music]
okay so that's an entity class
oh i see that's an implicit entity class
no that's an explicit one no that i i
know but i'm looking down here these are
implicit entities
right
entry classes within
that type
okay
i mean the second one of the classes
example is something you should look
carefully that you understand what it is
so yeah
yeah like it may make a
slash input form on the result that that
you are clear what happened here
why is that taking forever
that is not deployed yet so
yeah this was
why don't you tell me what the result
then was
make control z to go
back and then now type in slash input
form
so we did this canonicalization in this
step
which i feel has pros and cons
okay but i mean you could go both ways
here yeah because you could also say
let's shrink wrap this down to the
smallest entity type that applies
no
i feel like the only natural one they
shrink crap to the one you ask about
well that's fine but i'm saying that
another function could shrink wrap you
down
in the partial ordering to the thing
that is
most proximate to the elephant
yes
now as you could go both ways in this
hierarchy you could say
i mean what you should be able to do is
to generate the full hierarchy
up to the scoping type even beyond the
scoping type
in other words just like you can say
of an elephant it is in a certain family
phylum
class you know whatever kingdom right
you should be able to do that with
respect to the types here
and one could even imagine naming
just like one does in the taxonomic
hierarchy naming those levels in certain
cases
we could just have a new string
sub-value something like type hierarchy
yeah
that's fine and it could go
up upwards and downwards
of course then we need a little bit of
non-trivial return type a cough or
something like this
well i think that there's a
what's above you is always just a
sequence what's below you
yeah i mean you can have the sidebar you
can have the sidebars but but there is
always a
a way up to the scoping type is always a
linear sequence yes you're it
and
there's your siblings which might make
more of a graph yeah which might be also
worth having
i mean in general
in general it's some kind of directed
well it's a post set but it's also a
directed graph of some kind
um
let's see
so
okay let's keep going here just to
understand this so i'm not committing to
whether i think it's right
to return the scoping type
or to return
the proximal type okay or to return the
the input type i mean in other words
i mean clearly there's going to be i
think there might be an argument for
returning the scoping type because the
scoping type always can do
uh purely syntactic
equality comparisons right
it's canonical
the scoping type for an entity is a
canonical representation of the entity
yeah that was the idea
right
but the proximal type well i mean when
we say pro
i'm going to define terms here because i
mean when we say the proximal type would
be the most the smallest shrink wrap
type
around the entity
right
so in the hierarchy it is the last thing
on that sequence
does that make sense
you understand what i'm saying yes
no no i did not understand okay so look
look
you've got a hierarchy of types
there are types below animal
yeah right an above elephant
yeah right so imagine the sequence that
ends in elephant yep
okay so what i'm saying is
the proximal type
is the one immediately above elephant
i mean elephant isn't a type element
it's just an entity it is the thing if
you look at the type hierarchy i see
the last element of the top hierarchy
okay now if you go below
that in the type hierarchy so let's say
you've got to that thing i don't know
what an elephant is a pachyderm whatever
right
let's assume that's the
that's the last element in the type
hierarchy for elephant
now you could ask
you know
well clearly there are many siblings
there may be many other members of the
of the
of the subtype pachyderm
right
you understand what i'm saying yeah
okay so similarly as you go up so that's
at the level of
a type has many potential entities
within it
if you go up
the next level up on the type hierarchy
you'll get more entities and you'll also
get subtypes within that type
correct
yes
okay
so
let's take chemistry as an example okay
so i don't know enough chemistry to
really understand this but but there are
you know
in that case
i am a little bit confused that things
may overlap
the taxonomic hierarchy is by definition
a hierarchy so is the geo hierarchy
there's a hierarchy of administered
divisions correct
but if we look at for example
let's say
well let's talk about i don't know
uh countries
we might say countries that are
you know we might think
countries that are in the world health
organization versus the united nations
versus the world meteorological
organization
we might think of those
as subtypes but they are not
in this sense they don't form a partial
order
right they have overlapping their
overlaps right
so the question is under what
circumstances do we have a strict
hierarchy
of these things and the things that we
are calling types we are defining to be
things that live in this post-set-like
hierarchy correct yep
okay so in chemistry there are many
things that we might naturally think of
as types that do not have that
characteristic
there isn't the easy answer to this we
actually started discussing this whole
hierarchy things in chemistry but
it was just too complicated and the
various standards were
difficult and i feel like there's even
the equivalent for species if we take
different taxonomic classifications we
also don't have a unique version anymore
of this
so at some sense we have to commit to
something
but i mean
we there is a really practical thing
that i want out of this and that's uh
so we have this chemical entity type
that is a rather overarching thing
and we just over the years have put many
properties in there and it would be
convenient if we could have name some
subtypes that you want drugs
amino acids
drugs
right so um
no that's not gonna work
drugs is not gonna work as a subtype
okay it's not a subtype think about it i
mean you're going to want drugs you're
going to want hydrocarbons or something
those overlap but don't completely
they do not form a hierarchy those are
descriptive tags they're not
hierarchical
like if you go up to the original
example that's the that's the entity
so i generally
i i see this i mean from a practical
point of view i want uh
to have a property that only applies to
us
entity class i guess there are a set of
properties okay but that's a different
thing than we're talking about here
because this is a hierarchy and that's
not a hierarchy
that's a different thing
but even for countries it's not that
clear because you can have for example
dependencies which we have as countries
but you might not consider sovereign
countries et cetera so
okay well then this model is wrong
okay then this model is wrong
right forget the idea of using a post
set it's not going to work
so now what happens
if we say
well
within so there is a an enclosing type
that can contain
a
collection of subtypes
which do not form well
which
am i right they don't form a partial
order they don't they certainly don't
form a strict hierarchy
am i confused here i don't think i am i
think that you can end up with something
you end up with something which is both
is that what you're showing here i mean
look at this i mean like
it depends or if we allow the abstract
ones to be present or not if the object
ones are treated on equal footing it's
no longer hierarchical
right right right right so this idea
of above the elephant there is it's
you know family order whatever it is
right
that's no longer the case there's no
longer a strict hierarchy that goes up
to species
and in fact there's no guarantee that
we'll have a strict hierarchy
you know the only thing that is the
super thing is the concept of an entity
itself
right but the problem is
we've got to have
to disambiguate the names of entities
we've got to have some kind of scoping
type that does that
otherwise we have to have global
disambiguation which we do not want to
have right
okay so
in this case here
the thing has got to have
essentially a naming hierarchy
perhaps that's separate
from
its property hierarchy so to speak
am i making sense
i yeah i think kind of like what what
jason bix just said the the drugs i feel
like is an equivalent of the abstract
one
yes that's right
that's right yeah the hydrocarbons would
be a black one
i'm not sure about that
the distinction there is that i mean you
never have uh
an orange one uh inheriting from two
different black ones or an entity
belonging that's true different black
ones at the same level that is correct
no no no no no no no you well you can
have a hierarchy of beads of black ones
so to speak
but you cannot you're right you you
can't have a situation in which two
black ones
both lead to a subsequent thing
right
this exactly discussed me at the
beginning of this meeting before okay
okay
um
right and we we looked at it trying to
think of a
and a hierarchy from
you know uh just like element uh um
subatomic particles all the way up to uh
polymers or something but it didn't it
didn't oh it's the same no no no
no okay look
one thing is the naming hierarchy
the other thing is the property
hierarchy
those are two pragmatic reasons for
having this type hierarchy
they're not the only reasons there are
other things like you know
one can imagine containment
like you know quarxer and protons are in
carbon atoms are in whatever's
right that's a yet different kind of
hierarchy that has nothing to do with
the hierarchies we're currently talking
about
and we're making sure
so i mean maybe the right way to think
about it is
that given that we know there are
multiple kinds of hierarchies just live
with that so to speak and decide
that
again we have the naming hierarchy and
the property hierarchy are the two
obvious ones right
i don't know why you're saving this file
but do we have a um
yes you heard it directly
it's a call
last meeting went into the entity
framework folder
okay thank you
okay so what we're thinking about here
is something where we are
talking about
a
uh
you know we're talking about
the naming hierarchy
and
and also
the property hierarchy
now the property the naming hierarchy
has to be strictly
you know has to have this strict
ordering relation
whereas the property hierarchy
well what happens if there are two
things up here
it's winged and it's feathered
okay
so there could be properties associated
with its wingedness
and properties associated with its
featheredness
that are both mixed in to that
particular kind of entity
am i making sense
you you mean a bird inheriting both wing
properties and feathers
yes that's what i'm saying
right so
this is
um
okay so i'm saying this one
is a strict hierarchy
so that we we get from you know
it goes from you know from whatever from
from bird
to i don't know what the the no it from
from um
hawk
a particular kind of hawk
you know to bird
to
mammal
no not the mammal to animal
to
you know to species to whatever
right
and that is a naming hierarchy which has
the feature that
everything below
the terminal node of the naming
hierarchy or the top node of the naming
hierarchy must have a unique name
within that sub sub
tree which is
i think a reasonable practical thing to
do
right whereas the property hierarchy
was saying
in principle you could wheel in
let's say fins okay properties of fins
right clearly there are mammals that
have fins and there are birds they're
fish that have fins
and we could imagine a finned entity
where those properties
are available to both
so in other words what would happen here
is that for a given type
um
for a given type there is a list
of
uh
types
from which
it can inherit properties
right otherwise known as membership
basically of those
uh
you know
of those types
right now some of those types were part
of the naming hierarchy some of them are
not
this making sense
yes
okay we have a bunch of interesting
comments on our live stream here okay so
let's just look at a few of these and
then we're going to keep going down here
um
okay first marco is commenting
it would be nice if the yellow boxes
had some kind of way of pulling them
down to find out their properties i
fully
and wholeheartedly agree
why aren't we doing that i've brought
this up about eight times
do you understand what i'm saying that
for example
as a user assistance thing as soon as
you have as soon as you hover over a
yellow box for example you could have
something here that is the analog of our
information box
that i mean for example here there's
absolutely no reason why this doesn't
have that this is a piece of just
silliness
okay we should be able to have something
here where just like if i hover over um
the um
uh
just like if i hover over this right i
get an i here why don't i get something
when i hover over this
do you understand what i'm saying
but but not yet the actual data just
something that allows you to access the
data correct okay
i think we should have that right that's
a piece of it so feed that you know you
guys can think about that but it also
needs to be fed to the user assistance
crowd yeah
um and i think we just need to you know
fatten up
that
tool tip there yeah to contain that
extra information
okay let's look at a few of these other
comments
um
a meat says entity itself is variable by
function constructor entity
construct entities as functional tuples
i don't entirely understand that i can
guess a few different possible meanings
of that
um
uh
who's about this constructors before
forming type benches i don't really
understand that
bob is commenting on house cat's both
the type of pet and also type of animal
tomato is type of fruit and also type of
food yeah agreed
it's the same tomato
but now we're gonna get into trouble
there because let's take a tomato as an
example
right a tomato
i mean right now one of the issues we
have and we discussed this previously is
there's the tomato plant
and there's the
tomato
as a piece of fruit and there's a tomato
as a food
in some sense they're all the same
tomato but in some sense they're not
am i making sense
a chicken as an animal
i'm sorry
well i wonder that the plant will be
different than the actual fruit or the
food well fair enough i mean a chicken
running around is probably different as
chicken as a food
and arguably gold is an element
well that's a complicated case for
metals and things but but um certainly
hydrogen as an element
one can distinguish from hydrogen
as what as i mean
well as a compound it would be h2
presumably
now i'm confused
the
we can certainly distinguish element
from chemical even if they might have
the same name
distinguish in which sense
well i mean so oxygen
as an element
is a single oxygen atom or represents
something like the concept of a single
oxygen atom oxygen as a chemical is
presumably o2
correct correct
that's the molecular form of it yes
i'm sorry
that's
i'm well aware of that the question is
if i type in i'm well aware if i type in
entity
you know chemical
oxygen
okay
what is that okay so
is that if i say molecule
a molecule plot of
that what is it doing
there we go
okay hello so if you can now
uh output five is is the canonical name
molecular oxygen is my question uh no
it's not or i guess it doesn't
canonicalize just oxygen right right at
the end right so now what you're going
to see here is if i say element
oxygen
right
i'm going to get a thing which
represents a single oxygen atom so if i
were to say molecule plot on that what's
it going to do it is going to not know
what to do
interesting okay give it the rule to do
that no no no i understand it is not
obviously the obvious to me that ended
the oxygen represents a single molecule
in the element case
this case
it probably should but in this case it's
not tagging it so these have the feature
that they look the same but they're
actually different no but stephen then
like enter the
element for gold couldn't have a density
property if it would represent a single
atom
okay
i mean it's a possible viewpoint but not
one we have taken no i understand that
but then what is element oxygen
it's which as you say has a density
that will have a density at standard
temperature and pressure yes
which is a little bit weird
because its density is really the
density of a bunch of o2 molecules
running around indeed
right yeah no i agree it is weird but
but we always took some level of
obstruction without i understand so i'm
asking chickens okay so there's a
difference between oxygen as an element
and oxygen as a chemical they happen to
use the same english word to describe
them but they are tagged differently
just like a given word might have
multiple meanings
so i think that's okay
but we have to recognize
okay
so
again this is part of our scoping
types idea right these are in different
scoping types so they have names that
are the same
does that make sense
yes
yeah
and um
so well let me let me know that is
oxygen or the tomato example food versus
the fruit uh showed earlier there's a
non-trivial relation between them it's
not exactly the same but it's also not
truly disconnected i agree
i agree on the other hand
you know the town
called you know i think there's a town
called truth or consequences is probably
different from the television show by
the same name
yes
sometimes that's relation sometimes not
well but there is a relation because i
think the town agreed to name itself
that
you know in in return for having the
television show be filmed there or
something i see right so there's some
relation but it's hardly
the same relation as a chicken
as an animal and a chicken as a food
on the other hand there are other cases
where
the name of something just has
absolutely nothing to do with it's
purely coincidental that combination of
letters was used to represent that town
in wherever
and that it also represents some
different kind of thing
so
okay so there is i think
uh okay so let's so what we've got
is the notion of things with their
you know their scoping
type
and we could canonicalize you are
proposing effectively to canonicalize
always to the scoping type
right that's what you're saying yes
now
that of course loses information
because given only a knowledge of what
scoping type you're in you don't
necessarily know what properties you can
inherit
because the scoping type
you know species
has no idea whether it's got wings or
not
it's a type level
at the entity level we can figure that
out well yeah you know i understand that
but i mean so that's the question is
does it matter that at the level of the
type we don't know what the properties
are
then in order to find the properties in
order to find what properties apply we
have to go down to the level of the
entity or actually more accurately we
have to go down to the level of the
proximal type
right
or ask the entity what types does it
belong to and then and then get the
but no no obviously you can do that but
but the whole point is that we're
imagining that there is a strict
hierarchy of naming types
right there's a strict naming hierarchy
so then anywhere on the naming hierarchy
you could simply ask
four things with
with
well no i see i see i see
so it could be the case that some yeah
obviously some animals have wings and
some do not
so given only that you're on that place
on the naming hierarchy you can no
longer say
yeah right you can't do that except down
at the lowest level i think right
possibly even below the lowest level i
don't even know whether so we're saying
an entity has to carry information about
what
what abstract floating types
it could inherit
uh properties from so for example
countries
that are in you know the united nations
let's say
okay there might be a
uh
a subtype of countries in the united
nations which is ones on the security
council that year or something
right
which so by the way types are not static
in this sense
that being an example no not at all
yeah
so
but the naming hierarchy okay
and you're okay that's a good argument
for canonicalizing to the scoping type
because if somebody changes if we decide
it's really important that somewhere in
the chain of elephant
that we say that it's i don't know how
many toes an elephant has but you know
that it's it's really important that we
consider taxonomically
the thing to be a
you know a such and such toad pachyderm
or something
right and that we essentially insert an
extra level
in its naming hierarchy
that's you know we might want to do that
probably not for animals but maybe maybe
for viruses who knows i i could imagine
you know a change in the canonical
taxonomy for viruses
am i making sense
absolutely
substantial amounts of them
okay fine well but in that case that's
an argument for your assertion that we
should canonicalize to the scoping type
with respect to the name that we we
should normally canonicalize to the
scoping type
am i making sense
yeah that was to any suggestion always
okay fine well i'm agreeing with that
suggestion
okay
so
and uh forgive um
let's see so by canonicalizing like when
when we return the entity from uh from
some entity value call or something we
return it as it's uh um canonical uh
it's yes canonical form and i would even
argue that it should happen on
evaluation but we'll cross that bridge
later
okay okay
this i my dizzy cleavers because you
might want to
emphasize a certain frame of something
yeah well fair enough
but but okay so you're saying certain
functions will canonicalize ah that
that's not going to work but entity
value itself could do it entity value of
entity could do it
okay fair enough
because entity value currently um
so the the oxygen that you see there the
entity element or entity chemical oxygen
i was confused because i know that the
canonical name of that is molecular
oxygen but the entity itself did not
canonicalize it i don't know why i can't
tell you why
i mean how would we even get the
canonical name if that if that isn't it
and why didn't it canonicalize and isn't
that going to get comparisons wrong
if it doesn't canonicalize
right so those are good questions but uh
i guess
let's go back okay hold on but okay so
what we're i like to look at some more
comments on the
chat here but but um so what we're
understanding is given an entity it
inherits certain properties from certain
we can have a notion
of a
uh
the name shouldn't be propotiferous
property bearing
type
right a propertiferous type so to speak
that's a really terrible name but you
understand what i'm saying
do you understand what i'm saying
a type that has properties associated
with it
as opposed to a scoping type for example
yeah
right
which might also have properties
associated with it of course some
relation between these two things no i
know that a scoping type will also have
be a property bearing type
exactly
and vice versa the the scoping types
arise from the fact that
many properties are identical
i agree but the point is that we are
making a choice about a scoping type
based on the naming of things that's
that will be guided by that principle
right
that you know
animals have certain properties in
common that are different from for
example foods yep
um
but clearly that is an arbitrary human
decision
what
counts as a you know
a naming
a naming type so to speak
but i mean in principle like
vitamin a and oak is a totally fine
question but i want one
right
okay
okay let's let let me look at a few of
these other comments on our live stream
here
uh
marco
choosing the classification depends on
the sets of properties we need to
consider of the problem of hand yes
yes we agree and i mean there's there's
an argument based on what michael is
saying and so on that we say you know
that we should have a notion of property
costs so to speak
property can i don't know no no and
okay what this is a bad name but entity
type convert
which could potentially say
i've got an entity
it's a species it's an elephant
but now i want to convert that
i don't know why that didn't work it's
presumably more
specialized elephant here um african or
indian or whatever um
but in any case the the concept would be
that entity type convert could say
attempt to convert this entity
to type animal for example but
for purposes of reframing it yes
okay i mean we could reuse the two
entity function even for this
well that's an interesting idea
because two entity normally takes no
second argument is that correct
that's actually i believe already take a
second argument oh look at that
the specified type corresponding to expo
what do you know but right now
expert is typically not an entity
right try try try that's the obvious
thing to do with this i agree
i agree that's the obvious way to do
this
um
because the type is being specified
there same way we'd specify it here
exactly now now notice also
that we are
we are making an assumption here that
there is no scoping of the names of
types
right
me i'm not sure if i get the meaning of
the statement okay assuming
names of types are global
yeah that's correct i mean they're
string names
i understand but they're global in the
sense that that means that for example
we better not use
some as we start having these abstract
types we better not use some very
standard name and we have to be careful
about the naming of those things yes
yeah
right so
okay like like for example
a name like density
we presumably have to have you know we
can't say
no that's not that's not a type i'm
sorry the
um something like what would be a good
example something where we could have a
nasty overlap
um
[Music]
building
we have it already but it might be
already
um
i'm not sure that that's okay the issue
is two different color structure might
be a better example
two different kinds of things
are considered structures one in
chemistry and one made of concrete
so to speak
those are both type names
potentially
and they could have a nasty overlap
right so in other words
am i making sense so eg structure
is not
likely to be
a sensible type name
because there are two possible meanings
now i claim that's going to be rare and
i claim this is the thing we should
assume
i claim that the number of concepts in
the world is not large enough that this
is going to be a problem
let me clearly this is a judgment call
of a type we can't you know typically
have to make
um i think it's probably okay
all right let's see
um
approximately the defining
characteristics says james in the
absence of hierarchical subsets like a
venn diagram yes that's the problem is
that things don't necessarily form a
hierarchy
four is saying how long before we have
platonic ideal forms
yeah well
i'm just writing something about
this bizarre creature called the rouliad
that is deeply related to platonic ideal
forms
um
but
that's a few layers of abstraction above
this
um
is my cat asks bob
a type of cat or an instance of the type
cat
no it's an instance of the type cat
i mean
that's actually a good question and
this has come up over the years from
time to time
where we go to this absolute end of
being unique like for persons there's
just literally a single one but for the
species however he we we add far be
we add even basically before subspecies
for some things we go to subspecies but
we never go to the concrete item
well
okay
humans happen to be given names which
are not necessarily unique
but we have the idea that in the current
state of the world and so on a human is
a unique
identifiable distinct
concept
i suspect
you know the unnamed fish
in the school of fish
is a little bit less
obviously
you know then it's a less obvious thing
but you might have the two-headed snake
that makes it in the news
what happens with a two-headed snake
that's an interesting question for poor
siamese twins and things presumably they
get separated names
fortunately that's an evidence called
zone here
thanks i can't remember offhand how
we've handled siamese twins and people
data i'd have to go in and look at chang
and eng or whoever else we've we might
have in there
okay this is i'm just going to make this
typically that the known ones do the you
know each
each member has a each one yeah
dane is saying uh maybe classify
different types of hierarchies find a
set of useful ones yeah yeah i think
this is what we're ending up realizing
yeah bob sometimes something has a type
only if there could be more than one of
them
do we
agree type of all red things
as opposed to
the set of all things which are not
members of themselves
right
i don't think a type necessarily has to
have more than one of it i mean like for
example
among chemicals
we could say
you know we could imagine a type
that is you know radioactive elements
below
such and such and only technetium
qualifies
i don't think there's anything any even
that could perfectly well be a type that
somehow we specify which has nothing in
it for example it could be the case that
we have a type that we specified which
is members of the such and such alliance
of countries
and the such and such alliance blows up
and there are no members of it in the
future
yet
i mean what do we do with that type
presumably the type still exists and the
statement about the world is there are
now no members of this
is that right
i think so
okay btc is saying what is a thing
oh wow
it's a type of foliation with properties
categories relations and causal
relations
oh boy
those are two different parts of my
brain let's see if we can connect these
has anybody a curiosity question
in the world of sparklism so to speak
has that been described a bunch in terms
of category theory anybody know
i can certainly imagine how it could be
done i'm not sure it's terribly natural
didn't i not forward you some paper
about this a couple months ago tony
yeah there's some formalization
mathematical but
i don't know the details
i mean i think one of the issues is
so
one of the questions will be
is there any way to transport
it's like proof to people
i found it again
um
okay
yeah so i mean clearly you can formulate
just like you can formulate relational
algebra and things for databases and so
on you can clearly
formally make up certain
things like that whether that's useful
or not is unclear my belief would be
that the place where it gets interesting
is if you can transform
uh
you know if you've got one branch here
and it transforms to another branch
there is some correspondence between
branches like proof to proof
transformations
in in you know proof structures
then
that would get interesting and my guess
is that's not going to happen here that
is that they're the the case would be
two parallel hierarchies
that somehow map onto each other in some
natural way
can we imagine that well we could
imagine
yes
homomorphism
yes not as an isomorphism
probably
but i mean so so for example
the hierarchy yeah here's an example
the
the family phylum family order that
whole thing
is applied both to plants and animals
am i making sense
so in other words we happen to have the
same hierarchy and by the way
by the way oh i see
i no wait a minute that's a meta type
the order is a meta type is a name of a
as an okay so we also have the notion i
think
of meta types
eg phylum for example as a meta type
and we might very well want to be able
to tag
when we name a thing
we might want to say the phylum
blah blah blah
i'm making sense in addition i mean that
might also help with naming issues
you see what i'm saying
not fully
okay so look the the issue is
let's say we have i just don't know my
well let's let's do
um
let's let's do it in terms of countries
okay
we'd say you know
the country
singapore
no that let's take the administrative
division adm-1 let's say we're just
doing administrative divisions adm-1
singapore adm-2 singapore so to speak
those are potentially
this is a bad example
that's a bad example i'm i'm no it's a
bad example what i'm looking for is
in looking at plants okay
we can say this plant is a member of
this phylum this plant is a member of
this order
in looking at animals we can say this
animal is a member of this phylum this
animal is a member of this order
the the concept of phyla and orders
are in common between
the animal and plant types
am i making sense yep those are not
themselves types phylum itself is not a
type it is merely a type of type
am i making sense yeah i see what you
mean
right so there's always a concrete
phylum
but the whole point is is a tagging of a
type of type
some kind of meta type
and that was what i was saying earlier i
think it might be useful
to allow the possibility of tagging
types
if only just as a courtesy
so that you kind of know at what level
you know oh that's the
you know the order what is it squamata
for lizards and snakes or something if i
remember correctly but below reptilia
reptilia
um
am i making sense
so you're saying reptilia
what's that
like the types itself are in entities
and so yes
yes
yes and so there certainly could be
properties of the types
so that's a that's a um
properties
of types
as a per which which serve
you know
i don't see why we shouldn't have
properties of types
but i think we're going to need some
kind of way of
yeah okay so that's a separate issue
here we already have them right
for example you can have the count or
the
identity count
that makes sense right
okay that makes sense
but but are those
but we don't have that if i say entity
type
of country no wait a minute what is the
what is the tagging how do i get an
entity type
oh i see we reserved that i remember us
yeah the concept of an entity type is
something we do not yet have
that could be the fully decorated form
of
country for example could be entity type
country
that making sense
no no i understand i understand i
understand i'm saying when we write
entity
country that's a string name right
blah blah blah
it could be that the fully decorated
form of that
is entity entity type
you know country blah blah blah
and that could have some other tagging
but in other words the entity type
construct could be the symbolic
representation that represents that
whole type of thing now the alternative
would be
to have an entity
that is of type type
and to do this
see what i'm saying
yeah
such an entity type object might might
be useful uh in order to discover
relations between types you know yes i
think that
quite possibly true although we could
also do it using the entity type type
okay let's let's go back so that entity
type object could also contain what's up
you're very faint
sorry the entity type object uh could
contain uh sub-levels within it yeah
like so it might represent animal but it
could also contain the fact that it is a
taxonomic species that kind of thing yes
that's correct it could be much more
decorated
and even
if you ask for the entity type
somehow
well okay it can be a more decorated
version
okay so let me see
uh
properties being some decidable function
that assigns some semantic aspect
to a region of space time oh boy
i don't think
i mean not to get too philosophical on
it but i don't think everything is in a
region of space time
i think there are plenty of concepts
that we have about minds
that do not
can't be physicalized in that sense but
we can still discuss it even though it's
not or in mathematics
we can say
you know the group su-3
is not a region of space-time it is an
abstract thing
so i don't think we can i don't think we
can physicalize at that level
uh
bob is suggesting could we use fuzzy
logic
when does a finn become an arm
you see the problem here is
we have a descriptive language
and we have
sort of the state of the world
and
in a sense
what we do when we use language okay
the world has some some form atoms are
arranged in some way
we talk about those things in terms of a
much reduced description where we just
say it's an object
i pick up my
uh water glass or something
and
clearly
the definition of that water glass is a
complicated thing with all kinds of
atoms falling off it and you know things
being stuck on it and all kinds of
things like that but we choose to use
the linguistic description
a glass for example
and what we're dealing with here is
trying to describe the world at the
level of linguistic descriptions not
trying to describe the world at the
level of the way it actually is
and so
you know we would probably say
we will say
uh
you know
what would be a good example
we'll say the town of such and such
that's a bad example because that's
defined i mean in a sense
what legal systems have a habit of doing
is trying to turn
you know trying to make essentially a
linguistic description of real things in
the world like you say the town of such
and such
okay what really is that well you know
there might be a certain collection of
atoms that are you know a certain region
of space-time a certain coordinate
system whatever but this is going to get
defined
as something which is then going to be
linguistically referred to
so i think
okay that doesn't really answer the
question of finns versus arms
you know what happens is much more a
thing of like it's a good question we
see them a lot in
some query streams
it's often more a matter of definition
and some society makes the definition if
it's a thing or not
well what do you mean i mean so i i'm
look imagine what was that creature
called the thing that crawled out of the
ocean in the carboniferous period or
something yeah um i forget what that was
called but but you know it had fins that
turned into legs
right
what were those things
were they fins were they legs if we say
how many legs did a whatever that
creature was called have
what should we do
should we for that creature inherit both
fins and
legs a four or something for the count
of them
i would think
some
parallel society
made a decision and named it ease of
this all this it's not okay so michael
is following the legal theory yeah of
these things
but
linguistically if somebody asks at the
nlu level
you know how many how many legs did a
such and such have
surely we want to be able to answer that
right
i'm going to write down the the um
fins versus legs
uh somebody can look up what the
creature was called
um
see i would argue that a different
approach would be to say let it inherit
leg properties as well as fin properties
why not
like a a fin might have something to do
with it some
there might be as confusing like the
thing has four fins and four legs
oh you mean oh gosh right but the fact
that the fins on the legs are the same
things exactly we lose the
identification we need the non-trivial
machinery to identify them i see i see i
see is are the four fins
the same
as the four legs
okay
um that's a good question for wings
right i mean it could be the case that
that if you're uh
if you're a um
uh
let's imagine that you're a convertible
car plane object and the ends of your
wings have wheels on them and you put
them down on the ground and then it's a
a um yeah that that will get super
confusing
but again we can't describe
the the semantics the pragmatics or
something of how things are
we can only describe
you know what we're trying to do is to
find
a linguistic description of things
as opposed to a
sort of a material description of things
and yes we're going to end up in
aristotle's crazy thing which i've never
believed in
about you know
material forms and and
formal what is it i can't even remember
that hierarchy
the
uh
causes right material causes formal
causes
etc
it is a bit embarrassing that we're
still we're back to a 2000 year old
issue
but i guess that's the nature of things
because i mean that is the you know as i
recall the you know the aristotelian
hierarchy so to speak
anybody remember what that is aristotle
harris
talked
in the end well i don't know how to
spell it um
do you know what i'm talking about
anybody know what i'm talking about
have a diffuse understanding but no okay
so i think it's like the material you
know it's a thing it's made of something
material
the um formal cause
the i forget one of them and then the
final cause which has to do with what
it's for
and i think that's what we're kind of
trying to talk about here with respect
to things and i suspect that we have
a different
yeah we we will pragmatically need a
different slicing of things than that
okay
marco has
suggested check the bridge design
pattern it decouples hierarchies of
properties where they has a relationship
okay perhaps somebody can look that up
tony can you do that please
um
uh
fukamen says
is it it's possible for a given chemical
to be a drug and a pesticide so the
hierarchy isn't clear yes i agree
um
btc
better a thing or an object is a subset
yeah i i the subset of spatial
hypergraphs and so on i don't think
there is this is a linguistic
description of things this is not a
physicalized description of things
um
[Music]
oh boy we have tons of comments here
wow okay
well it's a complicated topic
um
foo is saying for the density example
diamond and graphite have different
densities but there are carbon yes
indeed
um
btc is commenting that fixed point of
the head function
on something eventually goes to symbol
the symbol symbol
now being discussed is a type type yes
indeed
that's that's the you know that
unfortunately is the way that things end
up working it's like
it is similar to in the evaluation world
to quote the quote of the quote so to
speak
it's it's some
uh
yeah it's interesting actually the way
that there's a
well anyway
um
uh okay btc is commenting convert the
red color of a piece of material to red
color of a charge of quark yes but
that's not a type i think
i mean i think we will be foolish
to
have those types of things as types i
think
um
yes btc is commenting evolution another
part of real space how whether whether
the subject object verb etc structure
and the way that we identify objects and
so on
is
unique and the answer is undoubtedly no
our market at the present time is humans
in the 21st century
so
therefore we are catering to the
description that humans in the 21st
century use of the world
which by the way is probably different
from the description
uh it's a little different than
description for example one time when
people were trying to do something like
this was the philosophical languages
developed in the 1600s
and they had slightly different
descriptors although fairly similar to
ours but we can imagine at some time in
the future yeah this notion of
identifying objects types of objects and
so on that is a pretty human thing and
certainly not a necessary feature of how
we describe the world um but
we are
you know
we're in the business of providing
things for humans of the 21st century so
that's what we have to do
um
and it is arbitrary but the generality
is nothing it's like saying
i mean in this in this theory of my
really add concept the only way you can
understand it is by coordinating it
which is essentially what we're talking
about doing here
uh
abstract entities like happiness and
hope
yes there are abstract entities
absolutely they're abstract entities
i mean do you you guys agree that there
are in this setup that we're dealing
with there absolutely can be things that
do not physicalize
right
right we have already now physical
system
there isn't an abstract tilted plane in
the world
yeah fair enough and we have words also
world data yeah
yeah okay
fair enough
okay group data
right
um
let's see
atc and electron
ah
electron on the surface of the snake the
snake the air
the air surrounding it yeah when
when does it become the air and when
does it become the snake when the snake
takes a breath
when does the
when does the molecule become a part of
the snake as opposed to a part of the
air that is why i am saying we are
merely making a linguistic description
of the world
not a kind of material description of
the world
um
there must be unintelligent types i
agree that there must be
um
okay that's interesting so btc is
commenting parallel matching across
categories is like a metaphor
that is
commenting that the word metaphor is
from the greek word
uh to carry across
metapharo presumably
um
that's an interesting i mean again we're
not going to capture
metaphor in the poetic sense
the question of whether i mean that is
that's an interesting term i mean maybe
functions should have been called
metaphors
in category theory never mind that
um
uh
let's see four is saying i think there
are going to be far fewer type
true type hierarchies in the world than
it would seem
um
again i think that
michael's legal
you know the legal concept of types
which is a you know in a sense the
quotes you know the legal concept of
types
is an idealization
of the linguistic concept of types
right it's it's some kind of
idealization of when we um
it's kind of like
a certain disambiguation yeah they have
all various possibilities but iupac said
this is what we do
right
so
and in that form in the legal concept of
types there will be strict hierarchies
just by definition now things may be
goofy there right
but
such as you know so it goes i mean
uh you know that there will be and and
i mean there is an issue which i think
we're slightly glossing over of what
happens if it changes
do we believe what do we believe is the
is the canonical permanent anchor
let's imagine that
it turns out people discover
that there are two kinds of indian
elephants let's say no doubt that people
already know that but actually great
example is lymphocytes
right back when i was a kid all you
learned was that there were red and
white blood cells
now there are a gazillion different
types
of lymphocytes
and so there's a question and maybe
somebody will say oh that was
incorrectly classified
what do we do
with what is our policy
on you know the cd8 positive
you know
helper t cell whatever thing whatever
the all the names are
um
how do we grandfather that
do you see what i'm saying
it's like the two stars that
that only now vcs2 and that were
classified as one star earlier yes yes
that's right
what do we do
every few years we update to the latest
okay but what do we do with it what do
we do with something that says let's
imagine that there's a as a proxima
centaur you know there's an alpha
centaur id or something that's
discovered
well that's not so difficult a new thing
discovered is one thing the issue is you
know two species break in uh you know
one species breaks into two
i mean we always or
okay we already have a minor planet
right
yes right
right planet becomes a minor planet
um
or more to the point we have a country
that breaks into
you know south sudan whatever it is
i know we have that case so what do we
do with that case so then then you know
the but i feel like that's not a problem
the problem where something changes at
the entity level this happens all the
time as we said earlier there are time
the problem is if
some
types go events will do falls off
wait a second but what happens to
there was a concept of sudan
presumably
and we've had this issue with historical
countries right there's a concept of
sudan but then it breaks into i don't
know whether they don't know whether
there's one surviving entity that's
called sudan and one that's called south
sudan i don't know how that was done
but
what i'm saying
okay but so the question is there might
be a surviving entity but you know who
knows maybe
macedonia or something kept
who knows i mean i'm i'm you know
misremembering history and so on but but
um you know you could imagine that
something kept the name it happens with
companies all the time that there's a a
you know
a good company name
that
some much smaller sub entity takes
and the main part of the company becomes
something different
see what i'm saying and so the question
is then for us
if we have okay so let's imagine
we have i saw facebook decided to rename
itself today
but um uh
you know we have a company
and boy this is confusing
[Applause]
i mean that that case is really ugly
because you know there could have been a
previous company that went out of
business long ago that was called
you know
i think facebook's renaming itself meta
right
um
it um
reminds me of
howard hughes right had a company called
summer
so
um who knows
the um
uh although i think that was of a
slightly different character
um
but in any case i mean you know a
previous name
what do we do with that we have a
canonical entity that's called summer
for example
which existed in the 1950s let's say
disappears goes out of business
then a new company comes on the scene no
trademark issue they name themselves
summer what happens to our entity
canonical entities
that's a question for alan i think
is alan still with us
i i would say kind of like we we have
some
we move it over to some historical
company and uh the current one is always
whatever it is
fair enough well that but that this is
an issue again alan should speak to this
but this is an issue that's obviously
come up with historical countries how do
we deal with this
okay
um
okay let's see
btc is commenting when there are direct
and undirected relations and those
beyond two edges a hypergraph seems
better for categorization of the
conceptual world look guys
let me let me say it again
it's never going to work as in
there is no
perfect
way
you know the world as it is
you know defined in terms of our
universe with its whatever it is 10 to
the 10 to the some number of you know
ultimate atoms of space or whatever
that is there is
we think now an ultimate description of
our universe but it is utterly
irrelevant
to what we're actually dealing with here
and when you try and put the screws on
the way that we actually describe things
as humans and think about things it is
always going to fall apart
there's just simply no
you know you can add a certain level of
precision
that allows you to do certain kinds of
reasoning
and beyond that
it's you know
you're you're descending you know the
best you can do probably
is to capture
sort of the
what a reasonable person would think you
meant
you know clearly you say a dog has four
legs but there's a three-legged dog out
there
or you know any of these kinds of things
there's always be this is not a um uh
you know this is a
there's a notion of useful reasoning
about the world it's the same thing in
in mathematics i mean you know for
example the fact that we say that zero
times x is equal to zero
is something where you could say no no
that's not always true what if x is
infinity
but it's still
a very reasonable thing to do to say
that zero times x is zero
even though
in the sort of ultimate description of
even mathematics that's not the case
so i think it's it's um
uh you know anybody who thinks
i mean what we have done for example
with wolfman alpha
and and now with the wolfram language
you know with all these frameworks we're
talking about here is we're trying to
make a reasonable
you know good judgment approximation to
how the world works
which is not to say that we're going to
get everything precisely right because i
claim that's impossible
i know maybe michael wants to make a
philosophical comment about this too no
no uh
i mean like
what like why do we do this because we
want to do practical things like we want
to find i don't know
metabolic scaling laws and such things
and so a convenient way to access the
data at a certain level is what is
practically useful i don't think that
this hierarchy that we built
on its own progress the world
yeah
right
no it's it's a okay fair enough
um
yeah four says i prefer to think labels
are put on things something more like
the output of a clustering algorithm
than the fuzzy boundaries yes i agree
it's like the meaning of words
you know words which develop multiple
meanings you could potentially see if
you think about word you know meaning
space
you'll gradually see those clusters of
instances of the use of the word
separate in meaning space
um
oh boy so many comments here um
uh
okay let's see eli is asking so in the
case of types
what would speciation
be like homomorphic paths between
different biological structures the
animals could possibly evolve towards
well okay so we're talking about i mean
yeah this is what we're talking about
about evolution of types
you know speciation
i mean i guess we can describe it in
terms of these uh type hierarchy paths
okay let's see
um the comment from uncomp
the set is defined by its members
they're just a set which contains all
globally defined types as distinct from
any other named entity which doesn't
have to be a type
so that is more primitive than global
types
oh no no we know this is going to get us
into another
morass of of you see this is the problem
with all of these global theories of
things
is so that the claim being made here is
a set
is more general than a global type which
is more general than a name
a set also has a name
mathematical exact schematic in having a
globally defined having
globally defined a unique type name
rather than a more primitive symbolic
set of names without
types i'm primitive i'm not getting that
i mean the fact is
you know the hack
on which wolfram language and so on is
based
is the hack that you can name things
with words that are sort of english-like
words
that is not a necessary hack
that is in principle if the system was
being used by computers
there is no reason to have a name like
plus
it could simply be the symbol 7426
that would be
just fine if all you're trying to do
is to make abstract reasoning i mean it
reminds me of the hilbert what did
hilbert say about about some
uh variable about um mathematical
concepts that they could as well be
tables and chairs or something
i don't remember that that's some quote
along those lines
but yeah you you know
we're essentially using the hack of
connecting to english which is a way to
connect to the way that humans view the
world which is not
the abstract way the world is or could
be it is merely the way that in the 21st
century we humans choose to think about
it
um
it actually is maybe there's no the way
it actually is yeah btc is commenting
there is no the way it actually is it's
the way i described in my reference
frame yeah yes i mean
what is a definition a definition is is
is merely the tag that we choose to put
on something
and then the question is does that
definition somehow maintain some
consistency
um
okay
foo is saying mud skippers can walk yeah
actually now that you mention it yes
those appendages are still fins and not
legs oh my gosh
okay well so long as somebody defines
them as finns in in michael's legal
concept of types we might still be okay
um
okay let's see four is saying build the
categories dynamically assign all the
properties to entities from human
literature then group according to
people how actually people talk about
them well that's kind of what we're
trying to do i mean we're trying to
curate this whole thing
from the actual practicality of what
people say
um oh yes but foo is now
descending into the mud
on the saying use the generic term
appendage rather than fin and leg yes
but
therein lies the path to
not to you know
drive the mud skipper too far but you
know by the time you're doing that you
say
uh you know you're
by the time you're genericizing at that
level you will rapidly lose the ability
to connect it to anything that people
actually think about
i mean that's the you know that has been
one of the mistakes sometimes in science
is to try and genericize things to the
point where nobody can understand what
you're talking about
um
okay let's see
four is saying perhaps we could borrow
concepts from functional programming
guise to deal with changes in hierarchy
i explicitly modeled time
i don't quite get that
um
oh boy parmenides is commenting
goodyear tires was started by charles
goodyear the person that went bankrupt
another company took
his tires and now has the current good
year
ah yeah right
um
right btc is commenting that um
um
our entity database
uh
might be part of the future hitchhiker's
guide to the galaxy so we should get
this right
we're gonna do the best we can but let's
let's remember
this is
you know
the abstract thing about the universe
the universe does what it does what we
care about is our description of the
universe
and that's what we're trying to capture
we are trying to sort of put in a bottle
the
the the implicit theory of knowledge
of the 21st century human civilization
and which is a little different
than saying let's describe how all the
atoms of space work
um it's saying let's describe things
that the 21st century human
cares about and by the way the 22nd
century human
might
have you know by that you know by the
time
there's a you know your average
augmented reality world looks quite
different people end up with a
completely different description you
know even different object borders and
things like that because you know if
you're not seeing invisible light you
might conclude different things about
what counts as an object and so on and
so on and so on i can imagine all kinds
of bizarre differences
but that's not what we're trying to
capture we're simply trying to sort of
put in a bottle the current uh
way that we think about things
which i think is is significant enough
um but if we try to go further we end up
with nothing
um
let's see
four is saying i think as much as
possible you should try to stick to the
mapping of well-defined blob of computer
data and messy world of language because
the reverse
is much much harder but we have to do
the reverse because people type things
in people expect to talk to their
computers and say messy linguistic
things
and you know what we've done rather
successfully with wolfman alpha and our
lu system which it was not self-evident
would work
is
we have
you know we do
pretty good automatic disambiguation
we thought that we would have to do much
more structured much more tiresome much
more human asking questions
disambiguation but the nature of a
complete query tends to correctly
capture
you know the disambiguation most of the
time so
it's it turns out that
language while messy and while it has
many many corner cases
is most of the time the central part of
language does fairly well
and is fairly easy to disambiguate
though there are corner cases and you
will never be able to stamp out the
corner cases
there
okay let's see
descriptive category rather than a
prescriptive credit you can still
extract those facts from your category
well yes that's this issue about whether
we're talking about naming
a naming type or a or a property bearing
type
um
okay so btc is commenting that open cog
uses hyper graphs you know we years ago
we we've interacted with these various
common sense knowledge
folk
and
the the answers were the the conclusions
were always unfortunate
um in the sense that we we really wanted
to try and make use of all the work
that's been done in those areas
and
and
for example one we looked at in
particular was solving math word
problems
where you ask a question like you know
uh
uh
you know
jim has
um
you know six marbles and puts two in a
bag how many marbles
does he have out now
you know things like that would be a
question of sort of common sense
reasoning but we never managed to
uh we never managed to make serious men
never managed to make that work
um
what is answer set programming from
logic programming well so again logic
programming is yet a different
kind of thing
where which we understand fairly well
now in terms of this whole multi-way
graph et cetera et cetera et cetera it's
really a thing where you're saying
you've got a multi-way graph of lots of
possibilities go find the one that
satisfies some particular goal
requirement
and i don't think that's i i don't think
i mean maybe there will be an issue
along those lines
in these type hierarchies
of uh will there be an issue like that
um
i don't know you you could imagine a
somewhat made-up thing of you know find
me a thing whose subtype is
yeah i could imagine something where you
say
find me a path
to things with wings
find me a path in the type hierarchy
that leads me to entities which have
wing properties
anyway i'm not sure okay we are
really over time here but um
uh
okay let's see marco is saying
suggestion is simply an entity should
have other entities which should also be
types
right well this is a question of whether
a type is
an a type of entity all right what else
did you guys want to cover here we've
we've gone deeply philosophical here but
um i think
uh
what is this down here
well this was the
the thing we looked at last time
the question was oh the question was how
do we name the relation between types
one being below the other
what do you mean by below we just agreed
that that wasn't a notion i mean in
other words we've got the naming types
which do form a hierarchy and we've got
the property bearing types
which
can have a more complicated relationship
where there can be multiple parents for
a given for a given thing
right yep
so what's the question here
i think
they hear concretely one for if you have
a custom entity store and you have uh
say the name naming hierarchy and you
have one down
uh what is the
string key on the left hand side
okay so i'm gonna make it very specific
i i know i'm going to make the claim
this is the wrong way to do it
i'm going to make the claim that the
diagram you had at the top that if you
want
a hierarchy
set up
well okay so my my first claim is going
to be you should explicitly declare that
hierarchy set up you should have a
symbolic structure here that represents
that type hierarchy independent of the
specifics of
you know
a particular type but you're going to
say why not okay so what one possibility
is from the outside describe the type
hierarchy
another possibility is from within a
type
talk about how it lives relative to
other
types mean practically like i think i
feel like there's slightly different
scenarios for us as
the provider of the whole world of
knowledge base obviously we have a very
complicated
and big
hierarchy but if you have your own
entity store you might just have two
levels deep with three different things
all right so but the question is there's
one fully decorated form which is the
the descriptor inside the entity store
that describes the type hierarchy in
that entity store and i think there
should be a way of specifying that that
is not that different from that graph
you had at the top of this notebook
am i making sense
yeah
but now the question is what is this it
seems overly very bold and complicated
well yes
i know but i'm saying that's the fully
decorated form
yeah similar to like a type environment
in some other
department in the company
well yes it probably is it's probably
similar we should probably find out how
that works in the compiler
how that
type environment description
language works and perhaps we could use
the same thing here
but in any case that's from the outside
that's the disembodied fully decorated
you know how types relate to each other
symbolic description
the second the separate thing is the
sort of cheaper version of this where
from within a type you're just saying
hey i want to grab all the properties
from this other but this other thing
exactly
okay so i think the mistake that's being
made here okay
is that you've got two types of types
one is
the naming types and the other is the
property bearing types
and i think that you have to distinguish
those here
when you're writing the thing out though
i mean it's convenient when you're
writing it out like they they could all
kind of seem like property types or
maybe
maybe well okay then you can declare
them somehow
you know you say this is a naming type
this is a scoping type
you got to tell it that somewhere you've
either got to tell it that at a top
level you know
sort of from the outside this is the
type
specification you know this is the type
hierarchy from the outside or you could
say from inside a type you wave a flag
and say i'm a naming type
am i making sense because somewhere it's
got to know that
and
th this subtype of i think that has got
to refer to there's two different
possible meanings there
this is the thing that is the naming
inheritance well this is the thing that
is property inheritance i think i don't
think some time
to enter these stores i think it will be
virtually always properties
maybe
i don't agree with you i don't agree
with you i think that the look the
naming
you have your own set of data from your
research and it's really always property
based
maybe okay but but i think the term
subtype is super confusing yeah that's
why we wanted to change it right well so
um
so something else basically like
property inheritance right inherits from
well no but it's not it's not inherent
it's properties
properties from
property source
property it's properties too
well okay but
this is uh that's we don't like to have
that
such a big sentence fragment you know
um so what we're dealing with okay so
this is entity store
design
um
and
what we're saying here so the question
is what should this be called this is
the thing that okay so one thing is
um
basically name
it's not predecessor what is the what is
the base
it's basically name
name base
name perry
yeah that's probably closer right
but it couldn't be more than one of
these
name parent types
because there could be more than one
couldn't there
no that's the ultimate there's one is
the ultimate
enclosing scoping type
canonical name
actually there is a notion of a
canonical type right the thing that the
thing canonicalizes too
is that making sense
yes but i'm not sure how this helps you
well but you need that information what
this type ultimately canonicalizes to
so for example when you register an
entity store
and you discover that
something with that canonical type
clashes in name with something else that
goes to the same canonical type you've
got to generate a message yes
right but that's exactly
not the evolutionary no no i i know that
but you've got to have a canonical type
you've got to know what the canonical
type is
and then
look basically what this is is
there's a notion of a type path
which leads you to the canonical type
right
type naming path or type path
you know how you get
up to the canonical up to
well up to a
a
a higher
named type because it could be like kind
of the you know like dns or something
you know in other words you're not
you're not getting quite too
you know eventually you get to the
dot-com domain so to speak but you could
be you your type naming path
um
look what you want is a
is a
a type from which
okay
look there's the there's basically a a
type
from which you inherit
exactly naming
naming rights or naming characteristics
and then there's the type
and that's a single type
no it's not a single type it's it's a
it's a single chain of types
single chain of types right
there's always one
yeah and the and at the end there's a
canonical type which is the end of the
line
and then the second concept is
types plural
from which you inherit
properties
right yeah
yeah
and i think for entity stores like
really the data you have in your lab
this is probably the more common one
okay well i'm not convinced of this i'm
really not convinced but but i think we
need both of them so
i have a question though um i mean in
the graph that tony showed you had um an
airplane kind of showed up out of
nowhere because it inherited from uh
this uh this winged entities
and uh but other than that i mean
um
isn't one of the distinctions between
the uh the property name spaces versus
the um the naming
uh namespaces are uh that that one hat
brings entities to it right so the
abstract types have properties but they
don't bring new entities
um why not
right
wait a minute
why do you agree i mean why isn't there
a way of asking give me all the winged
entities
yeah yeah you can ask that but
but it's i mean well it's still
they are all of the its types all of the
its entities
are
concrete entities of a a different
concrete
not necessarily type not necessarily
they
the winged type
could have
you know as a kind of a feathered winged
type or a a scaly winged type or
something but i would say every entity
in the winged type
category belongs to a concrete type
yes of course it does it belongs to
the naming hierarchy
when you when you put out these types
there will be those types which have
entities which are new in those types
which i i know i know i know that's the
point i was making about this naming
based types versus property
name carrying types versus property
carrying types
see what i'm saying and of name name
carrying types have a very
straightforward
inheritance hierarchy
property carrying types are more
complicated now you could give things in
terms of property carrying types there
might be an overlap there might be
somebody who's both a musician and a
painter
where do you put them
right
now you could say
let's just be fuzzy
and just generate an error if anna
appears both as a musician and a painter
right and only not generate an error if
in the type hierarchy you have something
like this
where this is i mean these these things
i don't think you should be using okay
it is merely a courtesy
to use property bearing types
as things in which you can name entities
of course
right and you can tangle yourself up in
a mess there by having overlapping
things and so on
right so
let's see so what we want here
okay so
i think we should describe what the
canonical form is
i mean what the sort of the fully
decorated standardized form is and then
worry about what the illusions for
convenience are
okay
and to my mind there should be a
declaration
of every entity
within a name based
type
a name carry a name-bearing type
okay so we have this notion we named
them differently above but name-bearing
types
and property bearing types
okay so the claim is that every entity
must appear in a name bearing type
and
it is an error if it appears it should
appear only in
well we could we could put it into yeah
i mean again
in terms of the entry the canonical
version
it should presumably what is the
canonical version of the entity store
is it
that it appears in its proximal
name-bearing type
do you understand what i mean by that
yes no
you understand what i mean yeah i feel
like it's a nearly irrelevant question
it's like what's the canonical form of a
time series
typically all right fine you shouldn't
look inside all right okay fine but then
then the question is can it appear
can anna as she does here
appear in two
i mean is musician a name-bearing type
no
okay fine
all right so person
okay is there any with respect to people
are there any name-bearing types other
than the person category
type
in that entity store no no no i i'm
saying in our knowledge base
is there a name bearing type
for people other than the people type
person type
so at the moment we have only name
bearing types and then
we might have sports
people okay which is wrong
which is wrong
i think the name-bearing type
from
well i mean
i think the feature of a name-bearing
type
is that it does have to have a strict
hierarchy it has to have a strict subset
relation
do you agree
but if it has no
relation then it's still a name-bearing
type right
sure
but if there's a if they're multiple
name-bearing type if there's a hierarchy
of name-bearing types they must be in a
strict subset relation
to each other
right
yes
okay as opposed to property bearing
types which are a free for all
but a property bearing type
lives underneath the name bearing type
that is a property bearing type has
apparent name bearing type
does that make sense
this was not the case for the original
diagram we started with
like the winged all right okay fair
enough no
[Music]
maybe it's wrong okay all right fine
maybe it doesn't have to
i mean the property bearing type then
could just be i'm giving you these
various random types
and when i refer to those types with
entity property i refer to them using
the name of that property bearing type
right
and i can just associate any
random i mean if that turns out to be
a property
of
you know time to balance a ball on its
nose
type thing
that could be applied to both a seal and
a
robot or something
completely different kinds of things
completely differently differently in
the name bearing
type hierarchy
but nevertheless having the same
property attached to them is that
correct
is that correct
i think so
um sorry he said it again okay i'm not
going to say it again because i think we
ran way over time here so i mean do you
think you have a path forward here
yes
why don't we i mean we got to clean up i
mean basically what's going to happen
here
is there are i don't know how canonical
you're going to need this i mean i think
we understand how these things that get
get attached
and um
uh
i think we understand that there are a
bunch of error conditions
in the entity store itself or in the
registration of an entity store
right and we've got to be able to detect
those
of things that you know are inconsistent
otherwise
you know i really do think that there's
a okay so for example you know this is a
question of how you store it and i don't
know but you know for a given entity
just saying give me all the properties
this entity has that's clearly going to
be an important thing to have
and you know i think the sort of the
rows and columns case
give me all well give me all properties
a given entity has
is going to be very useful give me all
entities that have a given property is
going to be somewhat less useful but
nevertheless important
and both have to be easily accessible
am i making sense
as it was in this third example in the
entity section
yeah okay fine fine so long as there's
an efficient way to do that we're all
good
but so here
the the question is
if you want to pull in
okay
i just don't understand how
i mean i don't understand this what's
the point of this why do you even care
in other words if you're simply
declaring
that
this instrument played what you're
trying to do is you're trying to scope
that property name
to say that that property name
is one that came from this property
bearing type
because property names
are not distinct
except within a given property bearing
type
correct
so really the only role that this has
is to say
i mean
i don't understand what role that has
is it is is what that's doing to
associate this anna with that anna here
exactly so
that's a different that's a different
role
it adds one edge in the graph
on the first graph on the whole notebook
yeah i understand i understand but it's
saying that
it's simply saying one of the properties
of anna
no one of the properties of
that
yeah you have the probability of another
musician rather than another pet which
could also be another type i know but so
so right but i mean the fact is
this is saying
that a musician
should have a birthplace
even though we might not know what it is
right right
and so when we return
i mean so one way to think about that is
when we say
birthplace of anna the musician
we would say missing not available not
missing not applicable
am i making sense yep
and that's in a sense what that's doing
for one
yes
okay so
well i agree that in terms of
okay
one thing is the inheritance of
properties which really isn't
on a whole type
basis
but every individual entity could
inherit different properties if it wants
it to
the only role of declaring it globally
for a given type here is name spacing
the property names i claim
so do we want individual entities to
inherit different properties but they
could if you said entity property of
blah blah blah you should be able to
inherit from wherever you want to
do you see what i'm saying
that the point is that look the role
okay two roles
of quotes subtype of
role one
uh
what is the name
name bearing type hierarchy
i.e you know
what
properties
should there inevitably be
should there always be
right i making sense
yup so we better not put in the
properties of a person
the generic base person
what
you know what books they've written well
maybe we could no we could do that we
could do that we just simply say
missing you know not available because a
person can write a book you know any
person could write a book
but
if we put in
uh
you know
um
something i don't know number of
well
okay
so okay what is the name bearing type
hierarchy what properties should there
always be and the second thing is
uh name spacing
of properties
specified
for this
for this entity
for for the entities given here right
that makes sense
yes
and i could imagine
i mean i you know i could imagine
wanting multiple ones of those so i mean
basically i mean property sources or
property
uh
property sources property source types
something like that property source
types
would be
that would be the namespace thing that
would be a list of of things where if
you see a name here
you go look it up in its fully qualified
form as entity property of
that type comma whatever does that make
sense
yes
okay now here
in the name bearing hierarchy
um
well this is much closer to some type of
because it does have to be hierarchical
i mean it could even be just called
supertype
goes to whatever
yes
or parent type
actually better to call it parent type
because it could be you could have
um
is it a single parent type
you see you might want to jump different
levels
yes we could we could have the weird
situation and i think trying to think of
an example where we specialize a type
into two different and they merge
further below now
so the only requirement is that we reach
one name bearing type
yeah
well so we could say name parent types
and then it's an error
if anything in the parent type hierarchy
you know we could have two parent types
and
no no no because we've got to be able to
just yeah okay parent types so that
could be different levels on the okay i
don't know whether there's an s there
that depends on whether there could be
different levels whether you just give
it
see
well this is my first attempt here
i think this is roughly right
and
i think it should be possible to extract
we need some functions that extract type
uh hierarchies and so on
so for that entity store we need a a a
property for the entity store
you know properties of the entity store
e.g
first one yeah type
type graph
[Music]
enter the type graph
something like that
i mean and then we probably want entity
type list and so on it's just vertex
list of that entity graph
so and and if we had an entity type
object we could ask for
well the connected component of that
type
yes i think so but i mean i think the
entity type object is a useful thing
because i think it will allow us to
distinguish things like property bearing
types and name bearing types
yes
and i don't guarantee that one day we
won't want a third one of those i mean
this is a classification
of sort of types of hierarchies of
things
i think we're implicitly updating old
aristotle here
it's not obvious how many times people
have needed to know this stuff in the
intervening years
um
i mean the last serious work that i know
of on stuff like this i think i mean
other than the the common sense
reasoning things which i think are
i don't consider to be particularly
strong in these in these areas
yeah was you know
a few hundred years ago
um
okay anything else we need to discuss
here
oh i think canada is enough to make some
progress and meet again in a couple
weeks
excellent okay this was interesting it's
always good to know that um
uh
yeah i mean the trick is how to not make
a mistake on things like this and i
think this requires
some level of sort of
philosophical pragmatism or something
and not probably in the sense of
pragmatism in the philosophical sense
never mind okay see you guys later
thanks and thanks particularly people on
the live stream lots of very good
comments thanks
okay bye